el sonido vuelve a los barrios de las
afueras de jerusalén es la primera vez
que las sirenas antiaéreas suenan aquí
desde la reanudación de la violencia
entre los militantes palestinos y las
fuerzas israelíes las sirenas son
seguidas por una explosión
es el sonido del sistema de defensa
israelí cúpula de hierro interceptando
cohetes ambas partes continuaron
intercambiando fuego durante la noche un
estadio en el barrio de jabalya en el
norte de gaza dejó varios muertos entre
ellos niños
estábamos en todos en la calle y de
repente vimos una explosión
vivimos corriendo y encontramos partes
de cuerpos de niños en el suelo no había
ambulancias
israel dice que un cohete fallido
disparado por la yihad islámica es el
culpable
sus militares publicaron este vídeo
señalando un proyectil perdido esta vez
no hubo actividad israelí en esa zona de
la franja de gaza ni en ese momento
hasta en los terroristas de la yihad
islámica dispararon un cohete hacia
israel que no alcanzó el territorio
nacional se quedó dentro de gasa
impactando en una casa palestina del
barrio de jabalya y matando trágicamente
al menos a cuatro niños mientras tanto
un comandante de la yihad islámica murió
a primera hora el domingo en un ataque
aéreo israelí
khaled mansur dirigía a las operaciones
del grupo en el sur de gaza su muerte se
produjo un día después del asesinato de
otro alto comandante de esa milicia el
ejército israelí ha advertido que su
campaña aérea y de artillería podría
durar una semana egipto mientras tanto
intenta mediar para terminar la atención